einen schönen guten Tag und Willkommen
zu ZDF heute live ja es ist ein
Wettrennen der Milliardäre und es geht
um nichts Geringeres als um die
Eroberung des Weltraums zu kommerziellen
Zwecken könnte man sagen als
Geschäftsmodell und dieses Rennen wollen
insgesamt mehrere Herrschaften für sich
entscheiden da wären die Personen Elon
Musk Chef von Tesla und SpaceX dann der
Amazon Gründer Jeff Bezos beide aus den
USA und der britische Milliardär Richard
Branson ja und der ist der erste von den
dreien der ist jetzt tatsächlich wohl
schaffen wird in den Weltraum zu fliegen
er ist nämlich heute dran genau und wenn
der Flug auch insgesamt nicht länger als
eine Stunde dauern soll oder eine gute
Stunde ist das doch alles sehr spannend
und wir sind wie gesagt live für euch
dabei sowohl beim Start in New Mexico in
wenigen Minuten als auch dann beim Flug
selbst und wir wollen das Geschehen
natürlich dann für euch einordnen Fragen
und Kommentare wie immer gerne an die
bekannte Adresse
kurz zu unseren Gesprächspartnern vor
Ort ist meine Kollegin Nina Niebergall
mit der werden wir auch gleich sprechen
und außerdem haben wir auch
hochkarätiges Fachpersonal dann an Bord
nämlich den ehemaligen Astronauten aus
Österreich Franz vieberg und in wenigen
Minuten auch die deutsche Luft und
raumfahrtexpertin Claudia Kessler die
uns dann alle wirklich kompetent noch
mal auch Details zum Flug und zu den
ganzen technischen Voraussetzungen
beispielsweise dies dafür ja auch gibt
dann erläutern können jetzt fangen wir
mal an mit Nina Niebergall meiner
Kollegin die New Mexico am
Weltraumbahnhof für uns steht da ist sie
schon da sehe ich sie und auch Herrn
Peter kann schon sehen hallo also
erstmal Nina grüß Dich vielleicht du
schreibst uns mal ganz kurz die Szene
was passiert da bei dir
ja genau ich stehe hier tatsächlich
direkt vor dem Spaceport America wo
Richard Branson gleich ins Weltall
fliegen möchte hier liegt tatsächlich
ein bisschen Anspannung jetzt langsam in
der Luft vorhin gab es hier hinter mir
sind die Astronauten sozusagen also man
nennt es astronauts natürlich sind das
eigentlich normale Menschen aber die
sind da Richtung Flugzeug gelaufen und
jetzt soll das gleich losgehen
Nina wer ist denn außer Branson noch
dabei insgesamt sind es ja sechs
Personen wer sind die anderen
genau also Branson höchst selbst ist ein
Bord drei seiner mitarbeiter:innen und
zwei Piloten natürlich die das
Flugzeug und später das Space Shuttle
dann Steuern werden genau also zu den
technischen Details die das ganze
funktioniert gucken wir uns gleich auch
noch mal einen Film an vielleicht jetzt
gerade noch mal ganz kurz weil es eben
auch ganz aktuelle Bilder sind der
sogenannte estronauts Walk also wie die
Astronauten dann sozusagen sich dem
Raumschiff oder dem Flugzeug erstmal
nähern das sehen wir hier da haben wir
Richard Branson 70 Jahre Abenteurer
Unternehmer und eben auch Gründer von
Virgin Galactic dem Unternehmen das
Ihnen jetzt sein eigenes ins All
befördert da gibt es noch mal ein Bussi
mit vertrauten genau also das ist
natürlich entspannter Moment und da
würde ich gerne auch noch mal unseren
Experten Herrn vieberg mit in die Runde
holen der fiebert sie sind der einzige
wenn ich richtig gelesen habe Astronaut
aus Österreich
weniger zur Sache aber sie sind
Österreich hier trotzdem vielleicht
können sie uns noch mal kurz erklären
was geht denn in diesen letzten Minuten
wohl vor so einem Start den Leuten durch
den Kopf den Astronauten
ja viele also volle Anspannung natürlich
und und ich glaube die meisten sind da
in einem in einem ich sage einmal
Funktionsmodus angespannt wie von einer
schweren Prüfung und ja da hat man einen
Prozedere das macht man durch bei uns
was ein bisschen anders ich bin mit
einer US-Rakete gestartet aber im
Prinzip ist da volle Anspannung bis man
dann im Cockpit sozusagen drinnen ist
und da hat man vorher viele mal im
Simulator geübt was man da machen muss
und ich nehme an bei den Kollegen die
jetzt den bereits im Raumschiff oder im
Flugzeug sind wird genauso sein ist das
so also muss man sich das vorstellen
dass man dann für sich komplett im
Tunnel ist oder redet man da auch noch
mit den Kollegen die er mit einem dann
an Bord gehen
also bei uns ist es so wir machen einen
Raumanzug angehabt ich nehme an die
Kollegen haben das gleiche das ist ein
Anzug der einem gefallen eines einer
eines verschwindend
verbunden und man redet natürlich mit
den Kollegen genauso wie mit der
Bodenstation hat dauernd eigentlich
Funkverbindung also Austausch ist schon
gewährleistet jetzt vielleicht die Frage
auch die sich unsere Zuschauer stellen
wie läuft dieser Flug insgesamt ab ich
habe es gerade gesagt es dauert gar
nicht viel länger als eine Stunde aber
ein paar Details dazu werden dann
vielleicht doch noch auch ganz
interessant und mein Kollege Christian
Volk hat sich damit noch mal etwas
genauer beschäftigt
in den ersten Minuten wird der
Raketenstart in New Mexico heute eher
wie ein normaler flugzeugstart Aussehen
hier Bilder von einem der Testflüge um
Treibstoff zu sparen bringt einen Träger
Flugzeug das Raumschiff auf 15 km Höhe
erst von dort startet das Raumschiff
durch mit dreifacher
Schallgeschwindigkeit also etwa 3.700
km/h insgesamt erreicht das Raumschiff
knapp 90 km Höhe von dort werden Branson
und seine Crew etwa 5 Minuten schwerelos
sein Branson selbst hat sich ganz
unbescheiden den Titel Astronaut 001
verliehen
neben dem Milliardär sind zwei Piloten
und drei Angestellte an Bord danach geht
es wieder zurück in Richtung Erde durch
die Flügel kann das Raumschiff wie ein
Flugzeug gleiten und landen insgesamt
soll der Flug etwa eineinhalb bis zwei
Stunden dauern
also könnte auch ein bisschen länger
gehen anderthalb bis zwei Stunden je
nachdem uns zugeschaltet ist außerdem
Claudia Kessler sie ist Expertin für
Luft und Raumfahrttechnik ein ganz
schönen Tag an sie auch und schön dass
Sie bei uns sind was ist für Sie als
Expertin jetzt die Besonderheit an
diesem Flug man stellt sich ja
vielleicht als Leihe da so ein
Raketenstart vor das ist es ja nun nicht
wie kann man sich das heute beschreiben
oder wie ordnen Sie das ein
ja das Spannende ist natürlich das ist
erstmal mit dem Flugzeug gestartet wird
und dann erst in 15 km Höhe ungefähr die
Rakete zündet das ist einzigartig bisher
als Staatssystem in der Form und
natürlich auch unheimlich spannende
natürlich einige Male viele Male
getestet worden vorher aber jetzt
wirklich als ersten richtigen Flug
unheimlich spannend und läutet ja auch
eine neue Ära der Raumfahrt ein in dem
damit ja wirklich dann die kommerzielle
Raumfahrt richtig losgehen wird ja über
diese ganzen Aspekte was das bedeutet
das jetzt eben da besonders
zahlungskräftige Menschen sich auch
privat engagieren werden wir dann auch
noch sprechen aber vielleicht kurz an
Sie die Frage werden Sie jetzt auch
gerne dabei in diesem Flugzeug
ja auf jeden Fall das war immer schon
mein Kindheitstraum selbst Astronautin
zu werden und wenn mich Richard Branson
angerufen hätte und gesagt hätte willst
du mit pflegen ich hätte sofort ja
gesagt ja das wird jetzt heute noch
nicht klappen aber wie gesagt die Herren
und überhaupt die ganze Industrie
arbeitet daran dass das in Zukunft dann
auch für Privatpersonen zu halbwegs
erschwinglichen Preisen möglich wird das
ist momentan noch nicht der Fall gehen
wir noch mal ganz kurz zurück nach New
Mexico zu Nina nibagall Nina wie ist
eigentlich dieses ganze Projekt dort
aufgenommen worden waren alle rundum
begeistert darüber das ist das dort gibt
oder gab es da auch kritische Stimmen
Begeisterung durchaus also ich habe hier
am Spaceport vorhin mit einer Frau
gesprochen die vor 17 Jahren sich schon
ein Ticket gekauft hat für 200.000
Dollar und sie sagt im Grunde das
war immer ein Kindheitstraum von ihr und
sie hat sogar eine Hypothek auf ihr
Hausaufgaben sie sich das leisten konnte
also diese Leute sind natürlich sehr
sehr begeistert ich habe aber gestern
hier New Mexico in dem Ort hier in der
Nähe ist auch mit Leuten besprochen die
gesagt haben so naja das kostet
natürlich alles ganz schön viel Geld das
sind alles Milliardäre die hier in den
Weltraum fliegen wollen und man könnte
mit dem Geld auch was anderes machen
dieser Spaceport hier hinter mir der
wurde beispielsweise auch mit
Steuergeldern finanziert den hat nämlich
der Gouverneur von New Mexico damals
angestoßen also durchaus auch die Kritik
kann man mit dem Geld nicht was anderes
machen ja also die Frage stellt sich
natürlich kann man mit dem Geld auch was
anfangen wir bitten die schlechte Ton
und Bildqualität zu entschuldigen von
Nina war jetzt nur ein Standbild zu
sehen das liegt daran dass die Leitung
ziemlich überlastet sind sie können sich
vorstellen da ist die Hölle los die
ganze Welt schaut auf dieses Spektakel
und darunter leidet dann ein wenig die
Technik wir hatten es eingangs schon
erwähnt es gibt derzeit ein regelrechten
Wettlauf der Milliardäre aber vielleicht
auch noch mal ganz interessant zu fragen
warum gibt es eigentlich diesen Wettlauf
und was bezwecken die Personen damit
mehr dazu auch noch mal von Christian
Volk
rund 50 Jahre nach der Mondlandung von
Apollo 11 gibt es einen neuen Hype um
den Weltraum diesmal geht es weniger um
Forschung es geht vor allem um Geld und
neue Geschäftsmodelle für Milliardäre
wie Richard Branson und Amazon Gründer
Jeff bacos es ist ein Wettrennen beide
wollen in den Weltraum und beide wollen
in Zukunft ihr Geld mit
Weltraumtourismus verdienen so schnell
wie möglich Branson will heute bases in
neun Tagen fliegen doch es gibt
Unterschiede Branson wird eine Höhe von
maximal 90 km erreichen basos fliegt
höher seine Raumkapsel soll auf 106 km
steigen zum Vergleich die Internationale
Raumstation ISS fliegt auf 400 km Höhe
die Fluggeräte der beiden sind wieder
verwendbar aber auch hier gibt es
Unterschiede Bransons Rakete startet von
einem Flugzeug aus 15 km Höhe er braucht
zwei Piloten
bei basos dagegen funktioniert alles
automatisch ohne Piloten er startet vom
Boden aus und dann gibt es neben Branson
und basos auch noch einen dritten
Milliardär im Wettrennen tesla-chef Elon
Musk sein Unternehmen SpaceX bringt seit
etwa einem Jahr NASA Astronauten zur ISS
ab September sollen auch Touristen mit
SpaceX fliegen und drei Tage lang auf
einer Höhe von 540 km um die Erde
kreisen mask will sogar noch höher
hinaus 2023 will er Touristen zum Mond
fliegen
schon bis zum Mond das sind also
wirklich ambitionierte Pläne wir wollen
uns vielleicht gerade mal ein Foto
anschauen das heute Richard Branson
getwittert hat und da ist er zu sehen
mit Elon Musk und schreibt dass er sich
freut auf den großen Tag der ihm da
bevorsteht und das ist ein schönes
Gefühl ist den mit Freunden zu
verbringen ja das kann man sich dann
jetzt sich dieses Foto anschaut richtig
vorstellen offenbar gab es da eine
Übernachtungsparty ich weiß es nicht
keine Ahnung jedenfalls ist Elon Musk
der also auch große Fehler die wir
gerade gehört haben offenbar auch mit
Branson befreundet und drückt ihn jetzt
die Daumen ist jedenfalls persönlich
auch anwesend Claudia Kessler noch mal
wir hatten gesprochen über Reisen in den
Weltraum als Geschäftsmodell das war das
Thema des Beitrags gerade wie klingt das
so in ihren Ohren
ja ich bin froh dass es jetzt endlich
losgeht ich habe schon vor 30 Jahren die
Idee mit mir rumgetragen dass man
endlich auch kommerzielle Flüge ins All
anbieten sollte und das ist ja bei
vielen Entwicklungen so dass dann
natürlich erstmal die Millionäre die
Milliardäre anfangen und es sich leisten
können dass dann aber auch die Preise
runtergehen und es natürlich auch für
mehr Menschen möglich ist ins All zu
fliegen und mir persönlich geht es da
einfach darum das kann der Feedback
sicher besser beschreiben dass man mal
diesen
Blick vom All auf die Erde und damit
dann auch ein ganz anderes Verständnis
für die Probleme hier unten auf der Erde
genau also mit diesen Ausflügen ins
Weltall da ist offenbar durchaus Geld zu
verdienen zu diesem Schluss kam auch
zumindest die Schweizer Bank UBS sie hat
veröffentlicht einen Bericht wonach
Reisen in den Weltraum bis zum Jahr 2030
einen Markt im Umfang von 3 Milliarden
US-Dollar darstellen könnten bislang sie
haben es auch gerade noch mal
angesprochen können sich das nur sehr
reiche Menschen leisten unter anderem
Leonardo DiCaprio und Katy Perry also
zwei Popstars sollen schon reserviert
haben alles eine Frage der Zeit bis es
dann billiger wird wie ist der ihre
Einschätzung momentan 250.000
$ für ein Ticket das ist ja schon recht
habe ich
ja das ist schon noch sehr teuer aber
Richard brandson ich habe heute morgen
gelesen dass das Ziel ist auf 40.000
Euro pro Ticket runter zu kommen und ich
sag mal das ist dann schon durchaus die
Überlegung kaufe ich mir ein Auto oder
kaufe ich mir ein Ticket ins All und da
würde ich definitiv das Ticket ins All
nehmen ja da gibt es wahrscheinlich
mehrere Leute die denken wie sie und die
Aussagen na ja dass wir halt vielleicht
einfach noch mal was ganz besonderes
inwieweit könnte denn die Raumfahrt
insgesamt profitieren jetzt von diesem
Engagement von privater Seite also was
Tempo was Dynamik vielleicht auch was
Nachhaltigkeit angeht
ja was Tempo angeht kommt da natürlich
ganz neuer Schwung in die Raumfahrt es
wird ja durchaus aus Wissenschaft
betrieben auf diesen kommerziellen
Flügen das heißt auch für die Forschung
für die Wissenschaft gibt es einfach
viel viel mehr Flugmöglichkeiten und es
wird auf lange Sicht einfach dazu führen
dass insgesamt die Staatskosten von
Staats ins All von Raketenstarts
günstiger werden vor allem wenn wieder
verwendbare Systeme wie Virgin Galactic
wie die wiederverwendbaren SpaceX
Raketen gestartet werden die dann
natürlich auch nachhaltiger sind weil
sie einfach öfter verwendet werden
können ich gucke gerade noch mal hier in
unsere Kommentare auch rein
stammuniversum über Youtube schreibt 80
Kilometer sind wirklich lächerlich
findet er oder sie hat mit Weltall
nichts zu tun Weltall das sind
Lichtjahre was sagen dann die beiden
Experten zu dieser Meinung
ja also offiziell es gibt zwei
Definitionen fürs Weltall früher gab es
die kammerlinie das sind 100 Kilometer
und in USA gab es aber schon lange die
50 Meilen Definitionen das heißt das
sind ungefähr 80 88 Kilometer und dann
ist man einfach schon so ja so aus der
Atmosphäre draußen und man kann die Erde
schon wirklich in der ganzen Schönheit
in der Krümmung sehen so dass das auch
als weltweit als Weltraum definiert
wurde als der Beginn des Weltraums Herr
Fieberg wie ist Ihre Meinung dazu also
das ist ja ich meine auch wenn man jetzt
sagt 80 km nur 80 km das ist ja trotzdem
oder 90 in dem Fall schon mit Sicherheit
ein sehr beeindruckendes Erlebnis wie
ist das vielleicht auch vor dem
Hintergrund ihrer persönlichen Erfahrung
auf alle Fälle also ob es jetzt 80 90
oder 100 Kilometer sind da gibt es
objektiv keinen Unterschied also man
sieht da keinen Unterschied der
Unterschied ist zu spüren circa bei 15
bis 20 km wenn man diese Höhe
überschreitet dann beginnt sich der
Himmel dunkel zu färben und wird dann
schwarz also das Blau dass wir hier auf
der Erde kennen verschwindet dann und
dann sieht man das Weltall und dann wird
die Atmosphäre schon sehr sehr dünn und
und das kaum ein Unterschied ob es jetzt
90 100 oder 110 km sind es ist er
ungefähr bei diesen 100 Kilometern die
Atmosphäre schon so dass wenn eine
Kapsel zum Beispiel zurückkommt zur Erde
in etwa in dieser Höhe sich beginnt
abzubremsen aufgrund der dichter
werdenden Luft aber wirklich Dichter ist
die Atmosphäre so bis ca Höhe 15 km wir
schauen natürlich immer mit einem Auge
auch auf den Start nicht dass wir den
verpassen also 16:30 Uhr unserer Zeit
sollte es losgehen sind wir jetzt schon
ein bisschen drüber aber noch ist nichts
zu sehen aber wir gehen natürlich dann
rechtzeitig drauf sobald es dann losgeht
aber Herr Fieberg weil sie gerade am
Erzählen waren was war denn die höchste
Höhe die sie bislang erreicht haben im
Weltall
Kilometer genau weiß ich nicht ich bin
damals zu mir geflogen und die mir ist
in etwa in der gleichen Höhle wie die
Internationale Raumstation circa 400 km
das schwankt immer ein bisschen weil
wenn auch dort in dieser Höhe kein
absolutes Vakuum ist und aufgrund der
Größe der Raumstation mit den
Sonnensegeln wird die Kranz minimal
abgebremst und fällt dadurch ganz
langsam zur Erde zurück und so muss
immer ein bisschen periodisch wieder
hinauf gehoben werden sozusagen in einen
höheren Orbit und unterher schwankt die
Höhe von der Raumstation im Mauer in
etwa 400 Kilometer war ich damals um
bedauern Sie ein wenig dass sie
sozusagen jetzt ihre aktive Zeit als
Astronaut jetzt schon vor einigen Jahren
hatten also wenn man jetzt guckt weil
wir das ja auch gerade besprochen haben
die Dynamik die jetzt in diese Branche
noch mal reinkommt ist natürlich auch
noch mal eine spezielle wären sie gerne
jetzt noch dabei
natürlich ist man gern dabei wenn man
einmal da oben war da ist mir infiziert
das ist glaube jeder der einmal oben
beim ist ist gerne wieder oben und und
genießt das und und wie die Claudia
gesagt hat das ist glaube ich gut was
jetzt passiert weil hier die Möglichkeit
geschaffen wird das mehr und mehr Leute
ins Weltall kommen und sozusagen den die
Schönheit unserer Erde und den Ausblick
auf die Erde genießen können und den
Ausblick ins Weltall hinaus und
schlussendlich hilft es uns allen hier
weil das Bewusstsein bei vielen Leuten
viel mehr gestärkt wird wir nehmen
unsere User noch mal mit rein Holger
Pier fragt inwieweit können sich solche
kommerziellen Weltraumflüge auf die
Unabhängigkeit und Authentizität von
Forschungsergebnissen aus der
Weltraumforschung auswirken wie
vorsichtig muss man denn diese
Ergebnisse bewerten
haben sie da eine Meinung zu egal einer
von beiden
Ladies first gerne
ja also natürlich gibt es da dann auch
Firmen die Forschung im Weltraum
betreiben werden aber das ist auch der
Ziel das Ziel der ganzen Sache auch die
NASA hat ja schon vor einigen Jahren die
Raumstation durchaus geöffnet für
kommerzielle Forschung und da geht es ja
um viele Bereiche die natürlich uns als
Menschheit auf dem Boden wieder
weiterbringen vor allem auch in der
medizinischen Forschung in der Biologie
biologischen Forschung in der
Medikamenten pharmazie-forschung also da
gibt es eine ganze Breite Bandbreite wo
wirklich interessante
Forschungsergebnisse gewonnen werden
können und das muss man sich einfach
vorstellen natürlich gehen Firmen hier
auch auf der Erde in Labor um dort
Forschung zu betreiben und mieten sich
ein Laborplatz und genauso wird es in
der Zukunft einfach im All sehr viel
mehr möglich sein
es gibt noch einige Fragen aus unserer
Community zum Flug selbst was kann
schiefgehen wie gefährlich ist das
vielleicht da noch mal die Frage auch an
den Astronauten selbst hätten sie
mulmiges Gefühl ein mulmiges Gefühl wenn
sie jetzt da dabei wären oder glauben
Sie nur das ist schon alles perfekt
geplant und vorbereitet
ja ich glaube schon dass die die
Kollegen die hier das ganze geplant und
vorbereitet haben sehr gewissenhaft
gearbeitet haben
nichtsdestotrotz ist es ein ein
gefährliches Unternehmen weil man eben
im Weltall ist und im Weltall ist Vakuum
das ist eine lebensfeindliche Umgebung
es ist vielleicht nicht so wie mit einer
Rakete wo man also beschleunigt wird und
dann schlussendlich mit 28.000 km pro
Stunde die Erde umkreist in diesem Fall
steigt man eigentlich nur in die Luft
und und bei ca 90 oder 100 Kilometern
ist dann die Geschwindigkeit 0 und man
fällt wieder zurück aber man ist im
Weltall und wenn man dann zurückfällt
fällt reicht das von Flugzeug auch
wieder eine hohe Geschwindigkeit das
muss abgebremst werden also sehr
dynamische Vorgänge und das ist durchaus
gefährlich kann durchaus was schief
gehen und daher ist die Sache sehr sehr
spannend
vielleicht an der Stelle auch noch mal
an euch die Aufforderung uns zu
schreiben also durchaus so im Sinne
einer Umfrage vielleicht also würdet ihr
gerne mal ins All fliegen wenn ja warum
oder wenn nein nicht ist es euch
vielleicht zu gefährlich also es wird
uns schon interessieren wie ihr das so
seht und ja und generell natürlich wie
auch eure Meinung dazu ist ob das jetzt
eine Spielerei ist von Milliardären oder
doch vielleicht eine wichtige
Zukunftsvision die man dann eben auch
mit praktischen Schritten vorantreiben
muss also ich höre jetzt schon
jedenfalls bei unseren beiden Gästen
raus dass sie das ganze durchaus eher
positiv sehen aber vielleicht doch auch
noch mal nachgefragt an dieser Stelle
gibt es da auch kritische Momente die
sie beide da auch manchmal haben dass
Sie vielleicht denken na ja gut also
wenn es da jetzt auch diesen Wettlauf
gibt zwischen den Superreichen könnte da
nicht auch vielleicht doch die
Sicherheit die Vorsicht ein bisschen auf
der Strecke bleiben
wie schätzen Sie das ein Frau Kessler
vielleicht zu Beginn
es ist ja wirklich so dass beide sehr
sehr lang auch getestet haben also
gerade auch der Virgin Galactic Flug der
hat sich ja sehr lange verzögert das war
ja schon vor ja für 2011 eigentlich für
fast vor zehn Jahren das erste Mal
angekündigt dass das jetzt dann bald
losgehen wird und das bald geflogen wird
sie haben sie vorhin gehört eine Dame
hat sich vor 17 Jahren schon ein Ticket
gekauft also man hat wirklich sehr sehr
viel in die Sicherheit investiert und
ich sage bei mir ist es auf jeden Fall
lieber dass es ein Wettlauf zwischen
Milliardären gibt als das ist ein
politischen Wettlauf so wie im Kalten
Krieg zwischen politischen Systemen gibt
also finde ich da haben wir doch
wirklich ein großen Schritt gemacht
sehen Sie das aus so Herr Viehböck
Leute das genauso ich meine
Konkurrenz ist immer gut und und das
bewirkt auch dass dass die Dinge auch
sicherer werden
wer wie schon mit einem mit einem
Flugunternehmen fliegen wo man weiß das
ist nicht sicher und und man überlebt
seinen Flug nicht vergleichen wir es
vielleicht mit der Flugzeugindustrie
oder mit den Airlines da ist auch
Konkurrenz und und die tut gut und jeder
versucht hier sozusagen noch bessere
noch sicherere Flugzeuge zu produzieren
und genauso wird es in diesem Bereich
stattfinden
Richard Branson das können wir an der
Stelle auch sagen es ist kein Geheimnis
ist nicht der erste gut betuchte
Weltraumtourist da gab es schon Menschen
vor ihm aber er ist dann doch der erste
der das ganze mit dem eigenen
Privatunternehmen durchzieht mehr zu
diesem Thema noch mal von Christian Volk
für Flüge ins All haben Branson und sein
Unternehmen angeblich schon hunderte
Reservierungen Kosten pro Ticket
250.000 Dollar der Weltraumtourismus
nimmt Fahrt auf und das obwohl es den
ersten Weltraumtouristen schon vor 20
Jahren gab
Dennis Tito ein us-investmentbanker
legte damals 20 Millionen Dollar auf den
Tisch für sieben Tage auf der
Raumstation ISS nach ihm folgten noch
sechs weitere Touristen alle unterwegs
mit russischen Sojus Raumschiffen
Branson und basers werden nun die ersten
sein die mit privaten und selbst
entwickelten Raumschiffen unterwegs sind
beide haben Ihr Unternehmen Anfang der
2000er gegründet und forschen seitdem an
der Technik bei Branson gab es mehrere
Rückschläge 2014 stürzte der damalige
Prototyp eines Raumschiffes ab ein Pilot
dabei ums Leben
tja also da hat schon ein Todesfall
gegeben gut das ist jetzt muss man sagen
vielleicht nicht unbedingt repräsentativ
das ist auch in anderen Branchen schon
vorgekommen wir hatten gerade die Frage
nach der Sicherheit schon gestellt und
sie hatten gesagt sie denken nicht dass
das jetzt gerade heute jetzt ein
besonders gefährliches Manöver ist bzw
eine besonders gefährliche Operation
wenngleich man sagen muss dass Aktionen
in diesem Gebiet immer mit einem Risiko
behaftet sind ich will gerade noch mal
gucken was wir an Zuschriften bekommen
haben
Felix dresser schreibt über Facebook ich
bin ganz froh auf der Erde zu sein mich
reizt es nicht solch eine Reise zu
machen aber ich denke das wird im Laufe
der Jahre immer normaler
was vielleicht noch mal an dieser Stelle
ist der Reiz warum wollen so viele Leute
offenbar also jedenfalls die die es
können so viel Geld dafür ausgeben in
den Weltraum zu fliegen was glauben sie
ja weil das eine ganz besondere Reise
ist wo man besondere Erlebnisse hat und
Eindrücke hat und und für sich mitnehmen
für das ganze Leben Erfahrungen die
unbezahlbar sind für sich und das
beginnt bei der Schwerelosigkeit das
Gefühl der Schwerelosigkeit dass die
heute bei diesem Flug heute vielleicht
nur wenige Minuten weil seit drei vier
fünf Minuten in etwa haben werden wenn
man zu einer Raumstation fliegt dann
oder im Orbit ist dann hat man dauernd
die Schwerelosigkeit das ist ein ganz
tolles Gefühl dann ist natürlich der
Ausblick auf die Erde ein ganz
fantastischer und schlussendlich der
Ausblick auch ins Weltall hinaus ist
sehr ergreifend und das sind Momente die
will man will man wahrscheinlich
erfahren und und nicht missen
Frau Kessler es gab die stimmen auch die
gesagt haben naja wenn man das möglich
machen würde den Menschen einer größeren
Zahl dann würden sie wenn sie den Blick
von oben auf die die Erde haben und auch
sehen was das letztlich auch für ein
naja gebrechliches irgendwo auch Gebilde
ist dann würden sie vielleicht noch mal
eine andere Wertschätzung für den
Planeten haben und für für das was wir
hier unten auf der Erde machen glauben
Sie das könnte so sein
ja ich bin überzeugt davon und das weiß
man ja auch von vielen Astronauten die
Bücher darüber geschrieben haben dass
das genauso ist dass man dann einfach
den Planeten als Gesamtheit wahrnimmt
und nicht mehr auf sein eigenes Land
oder seinen eigenen Kontinent schaut und
natürlich gerade auch wenn einem klar
wird wie dünn wirklich unsere Atmosphäre
ist ist natürlich das Thema Klimaschutz
was ganz anderes und auch kurz
unterbrechen denn das Flugzeug ist
soeben abgehoben wir gucken mal rüber
auf die Bilder die wir sehen aus New
Mexico und genau vielleicht können wir
da gerade noch mal weitermachen ich sehe
jetzt
einen Countdown gerade dachte ich das
Flugzeug wäre schon abgeholt und
wahrscheinlich nicht der Fall zu sein
okay also dann machen wir doch an der
Stelle noch mal weiter Frau Kessler ich
hatte sie unterbrochen also sie wollten
noch mal schildern sie glauben schon
auch dass die Wertschätzung der Menschen
die die Erde von oben sehen sozusagen
noch mal steigen könnte für unseren
Planeten
ja auf jeden Fall also es gibt ja auch
viele Stimmen die immer sagen wir
sollten als erstes möglichst viele
Staatspräsidenten möglichst viele
Politiker ins All fliegen gerade aus
Ländern die jetzt totalitärer regiert
werden oder immer noch Kriege
gegeneinander führen um einfach mal
festzustellen wir haben nur einen
Planeten und wir sind hier unten ja nur
ein eine Menschheit und wir sollten
eigentlich besser zusammenarbeiten statt
uns gegenseitig zu bekriegen
so Frau Kessler danke dafür und jetzt
gucken wir noch mal auf die Bilder die
wir gerade schon uns angeschaut haben
aber jetzt heißt es tatsächlich
000 jetzt müsste also demnächst das Bild
des Staats zu sehen sein und da können
wir dann gerne einfach noch mal zu dritt
auch darüber sprechen was wir dazu sehen
bekommen und momentan weiß ich nicht was
das jetzt hier noch ist ob das Werbung
ist oder wie auch immer ich gucke immer
noch mit einem Auge dahin noch sehe ich
kein Flugzeug das startet aber
vielleicht weiß das der eine oder andere
auch von ihnen was ist das denn dann
eigentlich für ein Flugzeug das in der
Lage ist so eine ja eine Raumschiff dann
eben nach oben zu transportieren ein
normales Linienflugzeug ist das ja nicht
wir haben es ja vorhin auch schon
gesehen das muss ja schon irgendwie was
eigenes spezielles sein
Frau Kessler wissen sie da vielleicht
näheres zu
ja das Flugzeug das Original ist ja weit
night das wurde ja hat gewonnen den
Google Prix Preis nein nicht den Google
Express den ans harry-x-preis schon vor
mehr als ich glaube 2004 war das wenn
ich es recht in Erinnerung habe
und da war eben das Preisausschreiben so
aller
den right Brothers den lindbergflug
damals der ja auch mit dem
Preisausschreiben seinen flugfinanziert
hat eben eine Million zu gewinnen um
wenn man beweist dass man mit einem
Flugzeug zweimal oder mit einem reusable
system zweimal ins All auf an die 100
Kilometer und zurückfliegen kann und das
hat die Firma damals gewonnen und dann
ist Richard Branson da direkt
eingestiegen und hat gesagt er gründet
da jetzt die touristische
weltraumfluglinie Virgin Galactic draus
und ich glaube zu den Strahltriebwerken
und so da lasse ich jetzt den Herrn
friebeck noch was sagen ich habe das
zwar auch noch nachgeguckt aber ich habe
es jetzt gerade nicht so präsent gerne
wenn Herr Feedback sich da einbringen
möchte
vielleicht können damit die Frage wieder
schlecht verstanden also es ging um die
Frage was ist denn eigentlich für ein
Flugzeug sein muss was in der Lage ist
eben so einen Raumschiff da auf 15 km
hoch zu bringen
ja das ist natürlich wie man sieht ein
kein alltägliches Flugzeug speziell
entwickelt wo einerseits sozusagen die
Last hochgetragen werden kann und 15 km
ist schon eine ziemliche Höhe wo man
nicht ohne weiteres rauskommt mit
normalen verkehrsfliegern konnten auch
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Kilometer
rauf aber nicht auf 15 Kilometer
und dann sozusagen auch die spezielle
Vorrichtung dass in dieser Höhe dann
sozusagen die Rakete oder das
Raketenflugzeug wie man das nennen will
so ein abgelassen wird und dann zünden
dann die Triebwerke und dann geht's
sozusagen hinauf ins Weltall
ja das ist ja auch ein ganz
interessanter Zeitplan also ich habe mir
das vorhin noch mal aufgeschrieben um
16:30 Uhr hätte es losgehen sollen dann
50 Minuten später um 17 Uhr 20 das
ausklinken in einer Höhe von eben 15 km
und dann nur 15 Minuten danach wäre dann
schon wieder sozusagen die Landung
erfolgt oder wird sie dann erfolgen
hoffen wir doch wenn dann alles gut geht
also das ist ja schon enorm also man ist
auf 15 bis man da oben angekommen ist
dauert es 50 Minuten bis man dann die
restlichen 75 etwa Kilometer
zurückgelegt hat und dann auch den Weg
wieder runter zur Erde dann nur noch 15
Minuten ist ja irgendwie auch
faszinierend
ja das ist deswegen das ist so insofern
ja das ist insofern zu erklären dass der
Flug auf die 15 km wie ein Flugzeug
funktioniert also das steigt langsam an
und gewinnt dann Höhe während dann nach
dem Abtrennen des trägerflugzeuges die
Kapsel oder das kleine Flugzeug wie eine
Rakete weiterfliegt das heißt da zündet
dann ein Raketentriebwerk und der Flug
geht dann praktisch senkrecht hinauf ins
Weltall also auf den direkten Weg und
das geht relativ schnell weil hier
natürlich auch ein entsprechende
Beschleunigung stattfindet und dann
genießt man drei vier fünf genau weiß
ich nicht aber ungefähr in diesen
Zeitraum Schwerelosigkeit und dann fällt
man eigentlich wieder hinunter man kann
es vielleicht
veranschaulichen wenn man mit einer
Rakete zum Beispiel immer Sojus ins
Weltall startet dann dauert der Flug bis
zu dem Moment wo man im Weltall die Erde
umkreist weniger als neun Minuten und
hat dann die Geschwindigkeit von 28.000
Kilometern pro Stunde das sind natürlich
enorme Beschleunigungen dahinter das ist
keine Frage das ist heute nicht der Fall
aber trotzdem wenn man auf dem direkten
Weg fliegt es ist ja nicht so weit von
15 km auf 95 oder wie hoch die maximale
Höhe ist das sind 80 Kilometer das geht
schnell wir haben jetzt Bilder vom Start
ich danke ganz kurz noch mal für diese
Ausführung wir haben Bilder vom Start
die wir jetzt gerne Ihnen auch noch mal
zeigen wollen und euch allen also das
ist da sieht man schon also dieses
Flugzeug sieht ja das ist ja wie so ein
Trimaran ja beim Segeln so sieht das aus
also mit im Prinzip drei Flugzeugen in
einem und da hebt es dann auch ab
und startet die Reise wie gesagt 15
Kilometer dann soll das ausklinkten
erfolgen ich weiß jetzt nicht welches
Bild was Material wir bekommen jetzt in
den nächsten Minuten wir hatten
eigentlich gehofft dass wir da dann am
Flug direkt auch ein bisschen dran
bleiben können und auch ein bisschen
beobachten können was da passiert an
Bord bzw eben auch in der Luft aber okay
wir müssen jetzt eben abwarten was uns
da die Veranstalter für Bildmaterial zur
Verfügung stellen im Moment haben wir
nur den Start jetzt mal ganz kurz
gesehen wie ist denn jetzt so der
weitere Ablauf oder bevor wir dazu
kommen vielleicht noch ganz kurz Frau
Kessler sie wollten vorhin auch noch
eine Ergänzung machen zu der Zeit die
mir etwas ja erstaunlich vorkamen
ja ich wollte das nur ein bisschen
anschaulicher darstellen also sie
beschleunigen quasi mit dem Flugzeug am
Anfang und dann haben sie ja den Schub
von dem Flugzeug und dann starten Sie
die Rakete wenn Sie sich das vorstellen
wie wenn Sie ein Ball an der Schnur
schleudern das ist quasi die
Zentrifugalkraft die dann schon mal
wirkt und dann lassen Sie den Ball los
das Flugzeug würde also weiterfliegen
geradeaus oder die
abgestoßene Rakete würde geradeaus
weiterfliegen und neben dem Moment
zünden Sie die Rakete und dann geht's
steil nach oben bis auf Mach 3 oder
macht 3,5 bis die Rakete ausgebrannt ist
das dauert ungefähr eine Minute und dann
macht die wie so ein Ball bei der
Wurfparabel einfach ja die Rückkehr zur
Erde die sie einleitet und in der Zeit
in der diese
umkehrbewegung stattfindet das sind die
drei bis fünf Minuten in denen man dann
schwerelos ist und dann fällt quasi
erstmal zu Erde zurück dreht sich dann
und irgendwann einen schönen Abend
dadurch dass das Flügel hat landet dann
eben wieder wie ein Flugzeug und wie
muss man sich den
platzvorgang dann vorstellen also das
sind ja unheimliche Geschwindigkeiten
wie wird das dann wieder rechtzeitig
abgebremst so dass es dann in einer für
Menschen überlebbaren Geschwindigkeit
dann auch auf der Erde landen kann wie
funktioniert das
ja das ist die Atmosphäre
genau Ladies first
sie haben heute den Joker ja
Atmosphäre
eingetreten ist ja
sie können das ruhig weiter ausführen
wenn es dann in die Atmosphäre
eingetreten ist dann kommt einfach auch
die die Aerodynamik wieder zum Tragen
und dann stellt man quasi dass das Paar
beim Shuttle ja ähnlich das ja dann auch
sehr aerodynamisch erstmal gelandet ist
und sich quasi aufgestellt hat um
tatsächlich mit der Atmosphäre mit dem
Luftwiderstand zu bremsen da kann es
natürlich heiß werden also das ist eine
sehr schwierige Flugphase auch dass man
da nicht zu heiß wird dabei und dann
wirklich auch gleichzeitig ja genug
abbremst und dann eben aerodynamisch
wieder landen zu können
ich habe jetzt nichts gefunden dass da
auch bremst Triebwerke drin sind oder
Bremse Raketen oder sowas noch drin sind
aber das werden wir sicher dann hören
wenn es soweit ist Herr fiebock ja tut
mir leid sie sind aber Kavalier alter
Schule und lassen der Dame den Vorteil
aber vielleicht haben sie noch
Anmerkungen zu dieser Frage also wie
dann sozusagen der Bremsvorgang dann
wieder läuft wenn die Maschine dann
zurückkommt das Raumschiff
es ist zum Space Shuttle ein doch ein
ziemlich gewaltiger Unterschied wenn der
Space Shuttle in die Atmosphäre eintritt
hat er eine Geschwindigkeit von 28000 km
pro Stunde ist es sehr schnell und durch
das Abbremsen durch die Atmosphäre
entsteht diese hohe Temperatur an der
Außenschicht und deswegen hat der Space
Shuttle dann auch diese dieses
Hitzeschild und diese Karten die hier
die Hitze aufnehmen das ist in dem Fall
heute nicht so weil im Prinzip der
Flugkörper eine Geschwindigkeit von 0
hat wenn er ganz oben ist wie die Frau
Kessler beschrieben hat wenn sozusagen
an der Spitze ist und dann fällt er
hinunter langsam und wird also durch die
Atmosphäre und durch die Flügel
abgebremst das heißt dass wir ein
Flugzeug
wird der Kreise ziehen und und versucht
so die Geschwindigkeit abzubremsen im
Prinzip wie ein Segelflugzeug und wird
dann zum zum Flugplatz hinziehen und das
akut gut landet also dass wir gesagt
erst in einem späteren Stadium des
Fluges also 50 Minuten so war die Ansage
jedenfalls wird es dauern bis diese
Flughöhe von 15 Kilometern dann erreicht
es wo das ausklinken erfolgt was macht
man denn auf dem Weg dahin Herr Fieberg
haben Sie eine Idee was da jetzt wohl
wahrscheinlich gerade in diesem Flugzeug
passiert da sind also sechs Personen die
dabei einander sitzen wie muss man sich
das jetzt ungefähr vorstellen
naja
die zwei Personen die sozusagen momentan
wichtig sind die sind die beiden Piloten
die die haben entsprechende
Verantwortung und Aufgaben zu erfüllen
die machen sozusagen ihren Job die die
vier Personen die sind hier ist ja
Passagiere im Moment wobei
wahrscheinlich die zwei Piloten im
Raumschiff selber momentan auch noch
Passagiere sind die Systeme pausenlos
checken aber noch nicht wirklich aktiv
dabei sind weil er noch das Flugzeug die
hängen noch am Flugzeug das heißt die
Piloten im Flugzeug selber in Träger
Flugzeug sind die die momentan aktiv
sind sobald dann das Flugzeug oder der
Raumkörper abgedrängt wird und die
Triebwerke zünden dann sind die beiden
Piloten im Raumschiff gefragt die dann
sehr aktiv sind und ihre Rolle haben die
anderen vier sind einfach
Passagiere die die aufgeregt sind und
die gespannt zusehen was da alles
passiert sobald man in eine hö schon ich
sage einmal 15 km kommt also in etwa der
Moment wo sich die dann abtrennen dann
färbt sich schon die Atmosphäre von Blau
ins Dunkle ins geht ins Schwarze und es
sind dann die Momente die man dann als
Passagier auch genießen kann vor allem
wenn es dann hinauf ins höhere Weltall
geht dann ist dann die Ausblick ins All
dunkel und man sieht mehr und mehr die
Krümmung der Erde man sieht ein größeres
Feld und das sind im Momente glaube ich
da wird jeder der vier Passagiere das
auch sagen wie ein Schwamm
klingt schon nicht so schlecht wenn ich
jetzt so von ihren höre dann muss ich
auch sagen ja also könnte man sich
vielleicht dann noch mal vorstellen
irgendwann dabei zu sein wenn es denn
dann irgendwie auch erschwinglich wäre
könnte denn diese Rakete also Rakete ist
es ja nicht aber dieses Flugzeug auch
bis zur ISS fliegen nein könnte sie
nicht oder oder auch das Raumschiff dann
später nicht
ja
Beschleunigung ganz andere Triebwerke
Treibstoff etc und vor allem bei der
Rückkehr
die das Raumschiff von heute das hat
kein Hitzeschild weil weil die
Geschwindigkeit beim Eintritt sehr
gering ist wenn es von der Raumstation
zurückkehrt dann hat sie sehr hohe
Geschwindigkeit und da braucht man ein
Hitzeschild um diese hohe
Geschwindigkeit von dieser hohen
Geschwindigkeit abzubremsen wir wollen
uns noch mal anhören einen Ton einen o
Ton von Herrn Branson der sich geäußert
hat zu dieser Konkurrenzsituation mit
den anderen beiden Milliardären bei
diesem Wettrennen ins Weltall mal hören
was er da heute noch mal zu sagen hatte
ich weiß dass mir niemand glauben wird
aber das ist ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
wichtig was wichtig ist ist dass wir
beide sichere Raumschiffe bauen es wird
ziemlich lange dauern bis wir genug
Raumschiffe haben um den Preis zu senken
damit junge Leute ins All fliegen können
aber das war bei den ersten Flugreisen
in den 1920er Jahren genauso
aber den ersten Flugreisen genauso also
er sieht dieses ganze Wettkampf Gedöns
sagt er jedenfalls nicht so aber
andererseits ich meine es ist schon
auffällig am 20 Juli wird Herr Bezos
starten das war schon länger bekannt und
jetzt ist er dann doch zuvor gekommen
also ein bisschen Eitelkeit glaube ich
spielt er schon eine Rolle oder Frau
Kessler wie schätzen Sie das ein
ja doch das glaube ich schon auch weil
das wurde ja jetzt schon relativ
kurzfristig dann verkündet natürlich
hatten die eine wahnsinnig lange
Vorlaufzeit und wir haben auch echt
schon sehr lange drauf gewartet ich habe
auch jedes Jahr gesagt naja hoffentlich
fliegen sie dieses Jahr endlich damit es
endlich losgeht mit dem kommerziellen
Flügen
aber klar haben die alle ihre Eitelkeit
und ihr Ego das da auch ausgelebt wird
aber das ist auch okay das ist auch
normal das haben andere Forscher ganz
genauso gehabt also wenn sie sich die
Schule werden Geschichten anschauen oder
auch die Historie ich meine also
Columbus und solche Leute die hatten die
bestimmt auch ein ordentliches Ego und
eine ordentliche Eitelkeit und da gab es
ja immer wieder Wettrennen sei es nur
mit dem Ballon was Branson ja auch schon
gemacht hat oder mit Flugzeugen oder in
80 Tagen um die Welt und so weiter
natürlich kommt da das Ego und die
Eitelkeit mit dazu aber es bringt
trotzdem den Fortschritt danach ja
vielleicht muss es das auch irgendwo
geben denn er geht ja auch ein gewisses
persönliches Risiko ein muss man ja
sagen
noch mal bestätigt das ist nicht ganz
ohne Gefahren auch so ein Flug und
insofern ist das vielleicht trotzdem
dann die Kraft die ihn antreibt um zu
sagen okay ich will der erste sein und
das ist aber dann auch die gleiche
Motivation die ihn dazu veranlasst im
überhaupt so starkes Engagement zu
zeigen oder wie würden Sie sehen
ja also ich glaube natürlich gibt es ein
Konkurrenzdenken aber aber
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob da jetzt
dahergeht so stark ist dass man sagt ich
muss jetzt unbedingt neun Tage vor dem
Jeff Bezos sein natürlich will man halt
irgendwo der erste sein
wobei ja er ist der Erste der
damitfliegt
in seiner Testflüge gegeben und und Elon
Musk seine Raketen sind schon viele mal
ins Weltall geflogen bei Jeff Bezos hat
Testflüge gegeben und und wie die
Claudia gesagt hat bleibt gewisse
sportlicher Ehrgeiz gehört dazu und und
das sind die natürlich an vorderster
Front
ja gut jetzt wollte ich gerade oder
sollte ich noch eine Information
bekommen ich frage gerade noch mal an
die Regie um was ging es
ah ja okay also in 25 Minuten soll die
ausklinkzeit sein und wir wollen uns
gerade in einem Beitrag noch mal
anschauen was denn bislang sozusagen zu
sehen war noch mal ein kleines ach okay
wir gucken uns noch mal an ich höre
gerade wieder Flug funktioniert dazu
noch mal ein paar Details
in den ersten Minuten wird der
Raketenstart in New Mexico heute eher
wie ein normaler flugzeugstart Aussehen
hier Bilder von einem der Testflüge um
Treibstoff zu sparen bringt einen
Trägerflugzeug das Raumschiff auf 15 km
Höhe erst von dort startet das
Raumschiff durch mit dreifacher
Schallgeschwindigkeit also etwa 3.700
Kilometer pro Stunde insgesamt erreicht
das Raumschiff knapp 90 km Höhe von dort
werden Branson und seine Crew etwa 5
Minuten schwerelos sein Branson selbst
hat sich ganz unbescheiden den Titel
Astronaut 001 verliehen
neben dem Milliardär sind zwei Piloten
und drei Angestellte an Bord danach geht
es wieder zurück in Richtung Erde durch
die Flügel kann das Raumschiff wie ein
Flugzeug gleiten und landen insgesamt
soll der Flug etwa eineinhalb bis zwei
Stunden dauern
ja von diesem Flug haben wir leider
jetzt noch nicht so viel gesehen außer
gerade die paar Bilder die es gab vom
Staat wir hoffen dann aber demnächst
noch einiges nachgereicht zu bekommen
wir wollen auch gleich noch mal sprechen
mit unserer Kollegin vor Ort in New
Mexico was ich da vielleicht neues tut
ansonsten haben wir an zwei zum Glück
fachkundige Menschen bei uns in der
Sendung die uns im paar Details immer
noch zu diesem Flug vielleicht erläutern
können jetzt überlegen wir gerade mal
also in 20 Minuten rund soll diese
Ausklingphase sein kann da irgendwie
auch was schiefgehen ist das ein
besonders normal neuralgischer Moment
auf denen irgendwie dann die Crew doch
irgendwie hinfiebern muss wie sehen Sie
das Herr Fieber vielleicht zunächst mal
natürlich das das ausklinken ist ein
sehr heikler Moment aus mehreren Gründen
das eine ist einmal das Los Training
muss gut funktionieren das heißt den
ganzen Mechanismen die hier arbeiten
müssen funktionieren das ist einmal
deine kritische Moment der andere
kritische Moment ist dass zum gleichen
Zeitpunkt das Raketentriebwerk zünden
muss und es ist halt immer Heike Sache
ob das auch gut funktioniert und ob das
rechtzeitig funktioniert und das Spielen
also schon sehr viele Dinge zusammen und
wir das spannender Moment werden jetzt
sind ja auch astronautinnen an Bord Frau
Kessler vielleicht ist das für sie auch
noch mal ja ein ein interessanter
Gesichtspunkt sie haben ein Shirt an mit
der Aufschrift Astronautin das ist eine
Initiative von ihnen vielleicht können
Sie dazu auch noch mal was sagen und
generell auch zu dem Gefühl was sie
haben das jetzt eben da auch Frauen mit
an Bord sind
ja ich bin natürlich sehr froh darum
dass Frauen nicht am Bord sind und ja
bei der Crew auch 50% Frauen das ist
einfach schon ganz wichtig dass wir
immer wieder zeigen dass es normal ist
dass Frauen ins All fliegen und dann
auch noch so international mit der
Inderin Cherry chapantler noch mit an
Bord also das ist schon eine sehr tolle
Crew und ja mir liegt es natürlich
besonders am Herzen dass mehr Frauen ins
All fliegen weil ich die Initiative
gestartet habe die erste deutsche Frau
ins All zu bringen es waren ja bisher
elf deutsche Männer im All elf deutsche
Astronauten aber keine deutsche Frau und
das ist für Deutschland als
Hochtechnologie Land natürlich schon ein
bisschen peinlich es war eine in Europa
eine Italienerin eine Französin
Engländerin im All nur in Deutschland da
fehlt noch und um das zu ändern habe ich
eben 2016 schon die Initiative gestartet
endlich die erste deutsche Frau ins All
zu bringen
wir haben in der privatmission zwei
Astronauten den ausgewählt aus über 400
ganz tollen ganz fachlich begabten
Ingenieurinnen Wissenschaftlerinnen
Pilotinnen und Medizinerinnen und haben
dann auch privat finanziert also auch
als kommerzielle Mission das Training
für die beiden astronautinnen
organisiert die haben das Basistraining
inzwischen abgeschlossen wir haben
parabelflüge gemacht auch um die
Schwerelosigkeit auszuprobieren um das
Arbeiten und Leben in der
Schwerelosigkeit zu üben die haben
Tauchgänge gemacht um auch unter Wasser
was ja sehr ähnlich ist dann auch wie an
der Schwerelosigkeit zum Beispiel eine
Mondmissionen zu simulieren sie haben
beide inzwischen den Flugschein
absolviert und fliegen auch regelmäßig
und haben eine ganze Menge technisches
Training gemacht zusammen mit Airbus um
die Systeme der Raumstation
kennenzulernen und auch mit Professoren
die ihnen die ganze Raumfahrttechnologie
noch mal nahe gebracht hat die beiden
astronautinnen dr Susanna Randal ist
eine astrophys und dr insecile aich ist
eine Meteorologin von der Uni Köln
warten jetzt eigentlich auf ihren Flug
trainieren natürlich weiter und wir
hoffen weiterhin das haben wir auch
schon seit Jahren versucht die deutsche
Regierung davon zu überzeugen dass sie
nach elf deutschen Männern auch die
erste deutsche Frau mit Steuergeldern
ins All fliegen wird
richtig verstehe Frau Kessler ein
konkreten Termin für diese beiden noch
wir haben eine Reservierung
nee es gibt kein konkreten Termin weil
uns die Finanzierung dafür noch nicht
sicher ist und wir müssen mindestens
zehn Prozent Anzahlen um konkreten
Termin zu reservieren wir waren mit den
beiden den USA wir haben mit Elon Musk
mit SpaceX gesprochen wir haben mit
axium sehr engen Kontakt die ja
kommerzielle Raumfahrtmissionen mit
SpaceX veranstalten und haben dort auch
eine Reservierung aber nicht für den
festen Flug das können wir erst zeichnen
wenn wir dann auch die Finanzierung
haben aber auch da geht es natürlich
darum Wissenschaft zu betreiben und
nicht nur sage ich jetzt mal symbolisch
die erste deutsche Frau ins All zu
bringen
Rollenmodell gut das ist klar der Punkt
ist rübergekommen wir wollen noch mal
ganz kurz Frau Kessler Dankeschön ganz
kurz noch mal rüber gehen nach New
Mexico weil wir jetzt im Moment die
Möglichkeit haben noch mal meine
Kollegin wie man Nina lieber geil zu
sprechen Nina also bei dir alles in
Ordnung wie ist die Stimmung vor Ort
gibt es irgendwelche Neuigkeiten wir
haben jetzt nur den Start gesehen warten
noch auf Bilder vom Flug hast du noch
irgendwie Dinge gehört oder gesehen die
für uns interessant sein können
ja ich hoffe zunächst mal dass ihr mich
jetzt besser sehen und hören könnt man
sieht jetzt hinter mir glaube ich ein
paar JournalistInnen das ist jetzt nicht
mehr ganz so interessant wie die Stadt
und Landebahn aber links von mir
trotzdem noch die new mexikanische Wüste
ähm ja so viel Neues gibt es hier auch
noch nicht also wir haben hier vorhin
mal ganz kurz Bilder gesehen von dem von
dem Trägerflugzeug von außen da sind
wohl mehrere Kameras drauf gerichtet das
wird also immer wieder Live Bilder geben
aber
durchgehend ansonsten war der Moment
natürlich wo das Trägerflugzeug
abgehoben ist spannend da hat kurz
vorher tatsächlich komplette Stille
geherrscht und dann Erleichterung es
wurde applaudiert also das war dann
schon ein besonderer Moment
kann ich mir vorstellen wie ist jetzt
der weitere Ablauf bei euch geplant also
die Landung war nach unserem
Kenntnisstand für 17 Uhr glaube ich
vorgesehen ich habe es mir irgendwo
aufgeschrieben kannst du da vielleicht
gerade noch mal sagen wie jetzt so
derzeit planen in etwa sein wird
aktuell weiß ich da tatsächlich nichts
Neues also ich bin auch auf dem gleichen
Stand wie du das 17 Uhr eurer Zeit ich
hoffe das stimmt dass ich das gerechnet
habe aber
genau ja also das ist auch mein Stand
nee da habe ich jetzt gesagt noch nichts
Neues gehört aber ich sage euch Bescheid
sobald das der Fall ist wunderbar vielen
Dank für diese Impressionen noch mal aus
New Mexico und ich denke wir sprechen
dann noch mal kurz weiter mit unseren
beiden Experten ich höre gerade wir
haben auch noch einen O-Ton von Herrn
Branson und den wollen wir uns dem
seit 17 Jahren haben wir 800 Ingenieure
im Einsatz sie sind nun bereit und wir
als Besatzung sind es auch wir sind
nicht weit weg davon Menschen mit
unserem Programm ins All zu befördern
mein Traum ist es dass junge Menschen
die den Flug sehen die gleiche
Begeisterung erleben wie ich bei der
Mondlandung vor vielen Jahren
[Musik]
sieht man so wenig von dem Flug und
kannst du uns da vielleicht was zu sagen
ich glaube das liegt daran dass eben
Kameras von außen darauf gerichtet sind
und die halt immer wieder Bilder hierher
überspielen und dann diese Bilder in den
Livestream den ihr glaube ich ja auch
sehen könnt
reingeschnitten werden das ist stand
jetzt wohl die einzige Möglichkeit
ansonsten ist auch für die Leute hier
vor Ort
warten gerade angesagt also die schauen
hier alle auf dem Bildschirm und warten
darauf dass es was neues gibt dass der
Moment wo das Space Shuttle mit Richard
Branson und seiner Crew losgelassen wird
dass der kommt ja auf dem Moment warten
wir alle vielen Dank noch mal Nina für
diese Eindrücke und wie gesagt da kann
man nicht viel machen außer eben darauf
zu hoffen dass dann gleich Bilder
gezeigt werden denn darum geht es ja nun
letztlich man will sehen wie sich das
Ganze dann auch vor Ort und in echt dann
entwickelt Dankeschön für den Moment und
wir sprechen noch mal mit unseren beiden
Experten mit Claudia Kessler Expertin
für Luft und Raumfahrt Technik und mit
Franz Viehböck Astronaut aus Österreich
ja also wir warten wie gesagt immer noch
auf Bilder vom Flug wir gucken mal auf
die Uhr also so ganz allmählich müsste
sich der Zeitpunkt dann nähern wo
ausgekoppelt wird und wo es dann
tatsächlich mit Macht drei weiter geht
macht drei was ist das für ein Gefühl
wenn man das so im Flugzeug erlebt oder
in der Rakete oder wie Herr Fieberg wie
muss man sich das ungefähr vorstellen
wird man da in den Sitz gepresst kann
man kaum noch atmen wie ist das
man fühlt im Flugzeug oder eine Rakete
die Geschwindigkeit fühlt man nicht man
fühlt nur die Beschleunigung das heißt
wenn man beschleunigt wird die
sogenannten GS wenn die ansteigen das
spürt man wenn das Flugzeug das
Passagierflugzeug in 10 11 Kilometern
Höhe mit 1000 Kilometer pro Stunde
fliegt spürt man gar nichts man merkt
nur wenn es gebremst wird oder
beschleunigt wird und genauso ist es in
diesem Fall da ist sicher die
Beschleunigung dahinter ich kenne die
genauen technischen Daten nicht wie
stark die Beschleunigung ist dass man
auf diese Macht drei kommt aber da ist
schon einiges notwendig und da wird man
sicher in die in die Liege oder in den
Sitz hineingedrückt das ist gar keine
Frage die Frage wird auch an uns
gestellt wie lange wurden die Personen
ausgebildet also Herr Branson zum
Beispiel mussten die auch im spezielles
Training unterlaufen oder ist das
sozusagen wenn man da jetzt nur als
Passagier dabei ist halb so wild und da
muss man halt weiß ich nicht körperlich
ein bisschen fit sein aber ansonsten im
Prinzip eigentlich nur gesund und dann
irgendwie machen was von einem erwartet
wird wie ist das wie wie schätzen Sie
das ein
immer die Frage an den Astronauten ja
also
Voraussetzung nehme ich einmal an dass
die gecheckt haben dass die Leute auch
wirklich gesund und fit sind das ist das
ist einmal
drinnen sitzen und und nichts tun die
müssen schon gewisse Dinge
sozusagen auch Üben und Trainieren es
gibt Notfallszenarien wo die also wissen
müssen was müssen die in so einem not in
seiner Notfallsituation tun aber das hat
dann auch schon also so gesehen sind die
Passagiere mit einer speziellen
Ausbildung für Notfälle jetzt sehe ich
gerade auf einem Auge hier noch mal
Bilder aus dem Flugzeug offenbar mit
einem Countdown auch bis zum ausklinken
wenn ich das richtig sehe werden es dann
noch ungefähr 14 Minuten da sehen wir
das gerade noch mal
aber das war's dann auch schon wieder
also wir müssen sagen es ist jetzt vom
Bildangebot her bislang nicht allzu
dolle da hat man es ein bisschen mehr
erhofft aber wir versuchen die Zeit
sinnvoll zu zu füllen sprechen wir
vielleicht gerade noch mal weiter auch
mit Frau Kessler wenn sie jetzt so
dieses Unternehmen sehen und sie sehen
auch okay es gibt nicht so wahnsinnig
viel Bilder ist es so dass
wie sie sich das vorgestellt haben oder
was glauben Sie woran es vielleicht
harpan könnte das jetzt doch so mal die
Übertragung vielleicht etwas hinter den
Erwartungen zurückbleibt
ja also ich habe eigentlich schon auch
erwartet dass wir permanent von der
Kamera im Flugzeug auch sehen was da so
gemacht wird was da so läuft also mich
wundert das jetzt schon ein bisschen vor
allem euch bei dem medienheim der im
Vorfeld ja betrieben wurde das jetzt
doch so sparsam mit dem Bildern ist also
ich hoffe einfach dass alles gut geht
und das alles nach Plan läuft und das
auch alle fit und gesund sind ich habe
gelesen dass ungefähr drei Tage
trainiert wurde vorher ich denke man
sollte auf jeden Fall wenn man selber
fliegen will auch ein paar Tage schon
mal parabelflüge gemacht haben die
Schwerelosigkeit ausprobiert haben denn
es wäre schon sehr schade wenn einem in
den fünf Minuten die man dann schwerelos
ist wirklich sehr sehr übel ist und man
dann gar nichts hat von dem Blick und
von der Schwerelosigkeit also
man sollte auch trainieren glaube ich so
ein bisschen über die eigenen Grenzen
hinauszugehen Dinge zu tun die die
ungewohnt sind um auch wirklich fit und
wach zu sein aufmerksam zu sein wenn man
dann diese faszinierenden Bilder erlebt
das ist ganz interessant was sie gerade
gesagt haben die Schwerelosigkeit also
die löst auch Übelkeit aus oder was ist
es was für für Unwohlsein sorgen könnte
wie fühlt sich das dann an vielleicht
auch noch mal gerade die Frage an den
Astronauten an der Stelle sie haben es
vielleicht selber auch schon erlebt also
ist das etwas was
womit die meisten Menschen im Alter zu
kämpfen haben
lieber mal so eine Zahl von ca 40%
gehört also es ist eher weniger als die
Hälfte aber es kommt vor dass es jetzt
eine Übelkeit kommt ganz einfach weil
das vestibularsystem das
Gleichgewichtsorgan gestört ist weil man
kein Gefühl mehr hat für oben und unten
man schwebt er die ganze Zeit und es
kann das kann Übelkeit hervorrufen und
es wird spannend wie es den Leuten hier
geht die claudia hat schon recht also
wenn man das vorher einige Male mitmacht
in einem Parabelflug dann kann man
Schwerelosigkeit für einige Sekunden bis
zu einer halben Minute genießen wobei
das schon auch sehr anstrengend ist weil
das immer rauf und runter geht und und
für den Magen ist spezielle Belastung
zusätzlich noch ist
vielleicht an Frau Kessler noch mal die
Frage wir haben es jetzt hier mit zwei
Amerikanern zu tun aber immerhin auch
ein Brite wie ist generell jetzt sehe
ich hier gerade noch mal Bilder die uns
offenbar zugespielt werden
1,7 mach etwas weniger sind das jetzt
Bilder live aus der
Kapsel ich kann es ihnen nicht genau
sagen ich glaube nicht ich glaube es
sind noch mal andere Bilder na ja gut
okay also Frau Kessler vielleicht noch
mal die Frage an Sie gibt es denn auch
Bestrebungen so was Privatleute angeht
in Europa also Branson ist Bräter aber
gibt es da auch die Idee dass man auch
vielleicht in Europa den privaten Motor
was was Raumfahrt angeht ein bisschen
stärker ankurbeln könnte
ja also wir haben ja in Europa bisher
keine eigenen Raketenstarts die einzige
Europa europäische Rakete ist ja die
Ariane die in Kuru startet also in
Französisch Guyana in Südamerika wir
haben Herr Europa einfach ja zudichte
Besiedelung und nicht wirklich die
großen weiten Flächen wo man gefahrlose
Raketen oder so raketenflugzeuge starten
könnte
insofern gibt es hier dann wirklich nur
also es gibt so ein paar kleinere
Bestrebungen in
Schottland im Augenblick um dort auch
Raketen Startplätze zu bauen aber ich
glaube das ist für kleinere Raketen und
nicht unbedingt für Astronauten gedacht
es ist dann schon so gut Virgin ist eine
englische Firma also ist eigentlich eine
europäisches Unternehmen aber gestartet
werden wird wohl immer in den USA oder
eben in Russland in Kasachstan einfach
weil da die Infrastruktur am besten ist
ja weil da die großen weiten Flächen
sind entweder sie Staaten aufs Meer
hinaus in Florida oder in Kalifornien
und sie wollen natürlich auch immer
möglichst nahe am Äquator sein mit so
einem Startplatz um möglichst viel
Schwung von der Erddrehung mitzunehmen
beim Raketenstart denn alles was sie
dann von der erdrehung schon als Schwung
mitnehmen können brauchen sie weniger
als Treibstoff das heißt die weiter weg
vom Äquator sie sind umso weniger umso
mehr Treibstoff brauchen sie auch beim
Start ja das ist ja auch irgendwie ein
wichtiger Punkt dass man eben Treibstoff
spart wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe war das auch einer der Gründe warum
der Staat jetzt erst im 15 km Höhe
erfolgt um Treibstoff auch zu sparen ist
es richtig habe ich das mir richtig
gemerkt Herr viehberg
ja das ist natürlich wenn man mit einem
Flugzeug wesentlich günstiger in die
Höhen kommt wo ein Flugzeug hinaufkommt
aber ein Flugzeug diese 15 Kilometer
viel höher geht schon immer mit einem
Flieger also ein
Düsenjet schafft dann vielleicht dabei
Kinder Meter mehr aber damit hat sich
dann bei ganz einfach die Triebwerke
Sauerstoff benötigen und der ist halt
dann auf einer gewissen Höhe sehr sehr
gering und daher verlieren die
Triebwerke dann stark an Leistung und
komme nicht mehr höher hinauf
verstehe Frau Kessler vielleicht reden
wir gerade noch mal über den dritten der
Männer der sozusagen heute eher noch
nicht so zur Sprache gekommen ist Elon
Musk mit seinem Unternehmen space Ex
bringt er schon seit etwa einem Jahr
NASA Astronauten dann auch zur ISS und
er hat längerfristige Ziele er will auch
den Mond tatsächlich
ins Programm dann mit aufnehmen will
2023 Touristen um den Mond herum fliegen
also ist das etwas was sie für utopisch
halten da glauben Sie ja das ist schon
realistisch
also es ist schon noch eine große
Herausforderung es ist schon noch sehr
challenge in das 2023 zu machen die
nasa-plan der 2024 wieder auf dem Mond
zu landen dann auch endlich mit der
ersten Frau aber Elon Musk hat
tatsächlich diesen Mond Rundflug
verkauft an den
japanischen Milliardär wo wir jetzt der
Name nicht einfällt aber vielleicht was
der Franz Ding gleich der dann auch
schon über Instagram und tik tok
mitfliegerinnen rekrutiert hat wo man
sich also bewerben konnte und Videos
einschicken und begründen warum man
unbedingt gerne mit ihm um den Mond
fliegen möchte
und also
Elon setzt sich ja immer sehr
herausfordernde Ziele aber er hat sie ja
oft auch erreicht werden wir beim
Zeitplan jetzt nicht ganz so sicher in
der Raumfahrt ist es durchaus so dass es
dann mal schnell ein Jahr Verzögerung
gibt weil die Sicherheit natürlich immer
am wichtigsten ist und das statische 2
ist ja jetzt noch nicht so oft
erfolgreich gestartet da gab es ja doch
eine Menge Fehlstarts bis der erste
Start dann wirklich geglückt ist und da
werden sich ja noch eine Menge Staats
nötig sein bevor man dann Menschen auf
diese Rakete draufsetzen wird
mich jetzt ihre Meinung auch noch mal zu
interessieren die Reise um den Mond
verlockend und auch realistisch aus
ihrer Sicht
natürlich verlockend gar keine Frage
realistisch auch allerdings bin ich auch
dabei der Claudia
2023 halte ich auch für zu früh soll es
zwei drei vier Jahre später sein es ist
trotzdem auch dann toll und und tolle
Sache ja was hier geleitet wird da sehen
wir gerade noch mal Live Bilder des
Flugzeugs und wir gucken auf die Höhe
46.000 Fuß ja also grob gerechnet
vielleicht 12 13 Kilometer also hat noch
ein bisschen Strecke vor sich aber ist
immer eben auch noch im Steigen
begriffen und man sieht auch die Erde
noch relativ deutlich da unten also das
ist jetzt noch ein Anblick wie man ihn
auch ungefähr aus dem Flugzeug noch
kennt bis es dann halt auf 15 km dann
losgeht mit dem Ausklinken und dann eben
mit dreifacher Schallgeschwindigkeit
wenn es mir richtig gemerkt habe mit
Macht drei dann hoch auf 90 bzw 95 km
so wir wollen noch mal gucken was unsere
Kollegin nie mehr Nina Niedergang Mensch
vor Ort macht wir gucken noch mal nach
New Mexico da sehen wir noch ein Branson
mit oder über Kopfhörer auf hat bleiben
wir noch Moment auf dem Bild was wir
gerade angeboten bekommen genau also
Sonnenbrille sitzt die Kopfhörer auch
und
gucken uns vielleicht gerade einfach
noch mal die Bilder an
die Onboard Kamera da sehen wir noch mal
die vier Personen die sich im Inneren
befinden und warten das ist dann gleich
losgeht mit dem Ausklinken und da noch
mal das Flugzeug genau so und das können
wir uns gerne noch mal ein bisschen
angucken ich weiß nicht ob die Experten
mich gerade auch noch hören ansonsten
könnte man da vielleicht auch noch mal
das ein oder andere zu sagen was dieses
Flugzeug angeht
ich frage jetzt einfach noch mal genau
Frau Kessler wenn Sie die Bilder jetzt
so Betrachten fällt ihnen da irgendetwas
ins Auge irgendetwas dass sie besonders
faszinierend finden oder worüber sie
sich wundern
ja ist natürlich erstmal super schick
alles das ist klar das ist ein ganz
modernes Raumschiff ganz modernes
flugraumschiff nicht zu vergleichen wird
der Franz sich ja gleich bestätigen mit
seriös Kapsel wo man also sehr sehr eng
aufeinander sitzt und natürlich muss
auch genug Platz sein weil man will ja
in der Schwerelosigkeit auch rum
schweben und das auch wirklich genießen
diese fünf Minuten lang das heißt
deswegen es ist natürlich auch und das
macht es auch den Unterschied aus auch
zu der Kapsel von zu der Crew Dragon von
SpaceX die ja dann dadurch dass das oder
auch von Bezos das ist ja dann doch
wieder sehr viel enger und sehr viel
mehr angelehnt an Apollo oder an die
Sojus Kapsel während man sich hier
wirklich dann wenn Schwerelosigkeit
herrscht und ich hoffe dass wir dann
auch Bilder sehen werden ja wirklich
sehr bequem und sehr weit auch bewegen
kann ohne um trotzdem natürlich ständig
aus dem Fenster zu gucken weil ich
glaube das ist so die Entscheidung die
man treffen muss mache ich jetzt
Purzelbäume oder wirklich weiter aus dem
Fenster und genieße den Blick Herr
Fieber für was würden Sie sich
entscheiden Purzelbäume oder aus dem
Fenster gucken ja
beides wie man man versucht dann jede
Sekunde optimal zu nützen und und alles
gleichzeitig zu machen es wird spannend
werden weil es ist dann schon eine
Herausforderung die müssen sich ja
losschnallen damit sie wegkommen von
ihren Sitzen wenn sie sozusagen
wurzelbäume schlagen wollen in der
Schwerelosigkeit und sie brauchen dann
aber schon ein gewisses Training um
wieder rechtzeitig am Sitz zu sein
hinzuschreben sich gut zu positionieren
und festzustellen das ist etwas das
haben die sicher hoffentlich vorher
geübt weil wenn man hier zu langsam ist
und den Moment versäumt wo man
angeschnallt sein muss bevor dann die
die
Bremsung erfolgt dann wird man irgendwo
in dieser Kapsel herumgeschleudert und
hat dann Schwierigkeiten seinen eigenen
Sitz wieder einzunehmen das klingt aber
in der Tat nicht ganz ungefährlich wie
übt man denn sowas diese
Schwerelosigkeit
das übt man wie die Claudia vor erzählt
hat mit sogenannten Parabelflügen die
kann man buchen da gibt es in Europa und
in Amerika verschiedene Unternehmen die
das anbieten da fliegt das Flugzeug
entlang zu einer parabelliste Claudia
beschrieben hat über meinen Ball wird
entlang der gleichen kurze fliegt das
Flugzeug und in dieser Zeit wo sich das
Flugzeug genau dieser Bahn befindet ist
man schwerelos das kann bis zu einer
halben Minute dauern und da kann man
halt Puzzle Bäume schlagen
verschiedenste Sachen machen nur muss
man schauen dass man rechtzeitig wieder
sozusagen angeschnallt ist wenn man den
Moment versäumt das Flugzeug kommt dann
in eine ziemliche Bremse und da wird man
sehr stark am Boden oder wo auch
immerhin gedrückt und und da kann man
sich schon ganz schön weh tun das kann
ich mir vorstellen wie gefällt ihnen das
Flugzeug sie haben es jetzt ja auch ein
bisschen gesehen das ist schon relativ
hat ein ganz charmantes Design
das ist so toll natürlich viel viel
Platz drinnen im Vergleich zu einer
soliuskapsel wo man in einer einbüro
Position angeschnallt ist wo es keinen
Raum gibt dann ist es natürlich Luxus
pur erste Klasse und und man sieht ja
auch die Passagiere sitzen so wie im
Flugzeug schauen beim Fenster raus bis
auf den Richard Branson der irgendwo
anders hinsieht also das ist schon schon
ein tolle Sache ja keine Frage ich frage
mich wo er hinsieht und was er denkt
aber er wird schon ein bisschen
angespannt oh jetzt ist genau das
ausklinken und jetzt sehen wir hier den
Antrieb vielleicht können da die
Techniker auch noch ein bisschen was
sagen Frau Kessler was sehen wir da
jetzt
ja also jetzt wird dann gleich jetzt ist
die Rakete gezündet sehen Sie die
brennen jetzt nur eine Minute
das ist ein butadin oligeme Oligomer
habe ich mir sagen lassen also ja was
woraus man auch ja Kautschuk oder so
herstellen kann wo man lachgastern
durchgepresst wird und wie gesagt brennt
jetzt ungefähr eine Minute und dann
beginnt schon die schwerelose also dann
hat man natürlich die Geschwindigkeit
noch und wenn die dann beginnt aber
schon so langsam wieder der Fall zurück
zur Erde also dann kommt wirklich der
spannende Zeitpunkt mit der
Schwerelosigkeit und das heißt also
jetzt im Moment aber wir sehen auch die
die km/h eingeblendet bzw die miles per
hour bei über 2000
drei oder sogar macht dreieinhalb habe
ich gesehen also wir haben jetzt nachts
0,8 2,9
jetzt geht's allerdings wieder etwas
runter
drei Null ja dann haben wir jetzt wohl
den maximale Geschwindigkeit erreicht
jetzt wird schon wieder langsamer das
heißt die Rakete ist ausgebrannt
und jetzt müsste die Schwerelosigkeit
einsetzen dass das korrekt
noch nicht ganz jetzt haben wir ja immer
noch diese hohe Geschwindigkeit ach so
aber
sobald die Rakete
ausgebrannt ist ab dem Moment ist man
schwerelos es geht jetzt noch ein
bisschen hinauf das heißt das Flugobjekt
gewinnt noch an Höhe bis sozusagen die
Spitze der Parabel erreicht ist und dann
kam sozusagen
Geschwindigkeit Null ja momentan steigt
es noch an genau ja die Geschwindigkeit
geht runter wenn ich es richtig sieht
die höchste geht allerdings noch hoch ja
genau
genau und da oben ist die Luft schon
sehr sehr dünn praktisch daher auch
keine Luftwiderstand und deswegen
Schwerelosigkeit
wäre natürlich schön wenn wir jetzt noch
mal die Onboard Kamera sehen könnten um
sozusagen auch damit zu bekommen was die
Leute an Bord jetzt machen ob Sie sich
für rausschauen oder eben dann doch für
die Purzelbäume entscheiden wir hoffen
dass wir da noch gleich Bilder
zugeliefert bekommen noch ist es nicht
der Fall noch sehen wir das Raumschiff
von außen ich gucke immer noch die Höhe
ist jetzt aber auch schon wieder am
zurückgehen das heißt man hat offenbar
jetzt schon den Scheitelpunkt erreicht
und überschritten und ist wieder auf den
Weg nach unten
bin schon wieder am weggeräumt genau
dafür steigen die Geschwindigkeit jetzt
wieder an
sobald die die Ehre Dynamik
zu wirken beginnt und das Flugzeug sich
wie ein Flugzeug verhält dann dann wird
wieder abgebremst und dann ist die
Schwerelosigkeit vorbei also das sind
diese drei vier Minuten vielleicht die
man da innen genießen kann
wie lange haben Sie Herr Fieberg die
Schwerelosigkeit erlebt also wie viele
Minuten oder gar Stunden oder waren das
Tage ich sie waren ja auf der mir bei
mir waren es Tage also acht Tage okay
acht Tage und wie ist das also auf die
Dauer was merkt man dafür für
Unterschiede am Körper oder gewöhnt man
sich überhaupt an diesen Zustand oder
ist es immer merkwürdig
also ich habe mich da sehr schnell
gewöhnt und mir ist da gut gegangen und
also von dieser Welt haben Krankheit
habe ich Gott sei Dank nichts gespürt
ich habe gespürt dass durch die
Schwerelosigkeit kommt zu einer
Verschiebung von Körperflüssigkeit in
die obere Körperregion speziell in den
Kopf und darf ich die ersten Tage drei
vier Tage lang Kopfschmerzen gehabt ja
das hat dann nachgelassen und und das
war dann eine super Gefühl
und das war also auch kein Problem nach
den acht Tagen dann wieder auf die Erde
zu kommen oder mussten sie dann auch
noch mal eine spezielle Anpassungszeit
irgendwie durchmachen
ja macht man mit wenn man schon ein
bisschen beeinträchtigt ist es wirkt
natürlich der 8 Tage bereits
Schwerelosigkeit die
Muskelatrophie ist das sehr stark und
man braucht dort schon einige Tage bis
man wieder sozusagen normal ist
jetzt vielleicht noch genau also wir
sehen nach wie vor die Bilder der
das Raumschiff leider immer noch nur von
außen nicht von innen wir wollten noch
die Purzelbäume sehen aber es heißt drum
ich höre gerade das Bild mal schlecht
von innen ja ganz kurz genau aber es war
eben leider von der Übertragung her
nicht so aber vielleicht kommt er gleich
noch mal was wir warten noch Oliver
krögel schreibt über Facebook was
passiert eigentlich bei der Landung
könnte die Rakete auf jedem Flugplatz
der Welt landen also Rakete ist es ja
nicht in dem Sinne
Flugzeug also dadurch dass es
wahrscheinlich noch relativ schnell ist
ich weiß nicht welche
Landegeschwindigkeit das hat braucht es
halt eine sehr lange Landebahn aber
ansonsten könnte es wahrscheinlich
theoretisch auf vielen langen
Landebahnen der Welt auch starten und
landen das ist ja auch durchaus das Ziel
des ganzen ja sollte nach Möglichkeit
wieder auf der gleichen Bahn glaube ich
landen wo sie auch gestartet ist sind
New Mexico aber ich denke das wird auch
alles richtig
berechnet worden sein nicht dass er am
Ende irgendwo in Paris rauskommen oder
sonstwo nein aber ich glaube das da
brauchen wir uns keine Sorgen machen das
wird schon das wird schon passen jetzt
sehen wir hier weiter Live Bilder das
könnte die Tragfläche gewesen sein oder
der Rumpf ich kann es nicht genau
erkennen
das ist einfach im Prinzip
glitters oder täuscht der Eindruck
das Glück nicht der Eindruck Deutsch
das ist jetzt wie ein normales Flugzeug
der Pilot ist da jetzt schon mehr oder
weniger im Landeanflug so hoch ist der
immer mehr was haben wir da jetzt glaube
ich 35.000 Fuß das ist jetzt normal im
Flughöhe von einem Flugzeug jetzt sind
wir die Kabine von innen aber jetzt sind
schon wieder alle angeschnallt
[Musik]
vielleicht haben Sie sich auch gar nicht
abgeschnallt in der Zwischenzeit das
weiß ich nicht aber jetzt gerade
jedenfalls saßen sie alle da mit
angelegtem Gurt
okay aber man ist offenbar guter Dinge
und freut sich
[Musik]
ja okay also alles gut gegangen und
man freut sich über
die Tatsache dass da nichts passiert ist
was ja auch verständlich ist das ich
denke ein bisschen Anspannung wird schon
dabei gewesen sein also auch wenn man
das alles gut vorbereitet und gut
geplant hat Herr fibox er hat uns gesagt
so ganz ausschließen dass da irgendwas
passiert kann man ja nie und insofern
klar wird die Erleichterung jetzt auch
da sein bei den Beteiligten schöne
Bilder jedenfalls aus der Höhe was haben
wir gerade allitude
32.000 Fuß
also so um die zehn Kilometer etwa rum
so und jetzt gucken wir gerade noch mal
auf den Zeitplan also 17
war ursprünglich mal geplant nee 17 20
war das ausklinken das kam ja etwa hin
und 1735 soll die Landung sein also ein
paar Minuten
ja etwa sieben Minuten höre ich gerade
soll also die Landung sich vollziehen
so und da haben wir noch mal Bilder vom
Weltraumbahnhof in New Mexico auch da
wird gewunken und die Leute sind happy
gut jetzt bricht gerade das Bild ab so
dann fragen wir vielleicht gerade noch
mal einfach in die Runde ja bei Herrn
Fieber vielleicht noch mal nach also sie
haben jetzt auch die ja da sind jetzt
wieder Bilder vom Raumschiff aber sie
haben es jetzt ja im Prinzip auch
gesehen also würden Sie sagen alles gut
gelaufen es gibt eigentlich keine
Hinweise darauf dass da jetzt irgendwie
was schlecht geklappt oder irgendwie
nicht gut funktioniert haben könnte oder
ja also
toll aus und ich vermute dass auch am
Schluss nichts mehr passieren wird
hier sieht man Richard Branson
tolle Leistung von ihm das einzige
ach er hört auch ich versuche gerade mal
zuzuhören was er zu erzählen hat
also Glückwunsch an alle die beteiligt
waren
und das war eine Erfahrung die er in
seinem ganzen Leben nicht mehr vergessen
wird
ja also voller Euphorie kann man sich
vorstellen also dankt allen und ist
happy und hat eine einzigartige
Erfahrung machen dürfen
sicher toll was er gemacht hat ich würde
sagen in Bezug auf Marketing können sich
die bei Red Bull wahrscheinlich einiges
noch abschauen ja das müssen sie als
Österreicher natürlich sagen muss ich
sagen was mich ein bisschen stört hat
beim
tolle Sache was er gemacht hat aber
dass er sich erst dann
der einen und Flug um die Welt gemacht
hat nein 69
abgehackt aber ich glaube der Punkt ist
rübergekommen also der 001 diese
Bezeichnung ist eigentlich Juri Gagarin
vorbehalten haben sie gesagt ein
bisschen anmaßend eventuell das Herr
Branson sich da jetzt auch so genannt
hat ja da gibt es natürlich schon auch
Empfindlichkeiten in der Branche und da
sollte man vielleicht auch etwas mehr
drauf achten dass mag wohl so sein
Richard Branson natürlich eine
schillernde Figur der ja auch als
Abenteurer schon für einige Schlagzeilen
gesorgt hat der den Ärmelkanal mit dem
Kitesurfen mit mit einem Drachen
sozusagen überquert hat der mit dem
Heißluftballon mehrfach versucht hat die
Erde zum runden ist fast geschafft hätte
also der hat schon viele interessante
Sachen auf die Beine gestellt neben
seinen ganzen unternehmerischen
Tätigkeiten natürlich
ja da wird schon telefoniert
gut er sagt noch mal wann er zu Hause
ist wahrscheinlich ja bestellt schon den
Kaffee wir wissen es nicht genau
jedenfalls es scheint eine gute Stimmung
zu sein an Bord eben dieses
Flugzeugs so und da sind noch mal die
Bilder über der Wüste von New Mexico
jawohl also hat ihnen beiden das wird
werden sie sich bemühen um Tickets Frau
Kessler
weil sie auch dabei sein wenn es dann
demnächst wieder ja
ich habe schon vor zwei Jahren eine
Option gekauft da gab es mal die
Möglichkeit für 1000 Euro sich auf jeden
Fall mal eine Option auf dem Ticket zu
sichern und das habe ich tatsächlich
dann sofort gemacht ja also ich habe da
schon ich warte natürlich noch bis die
Preise runtergehen also die 250.000
werde ich mir glaube ich nicht leisten
können da müsste ich schon noch sehr
reich werden aber wie gesagt also wenn
es auf unter 50.000 geht dann ist es
durchaus eine Überlegung die vielleicht
noch machbar ist ja und diese 1000 Euro
für was war das auf jeden Fall machen wo
könnten sie damit fahren das war quasi
eine Option es gibt ja so viele Menschen
er hat ja wie gesagt schon 600 Tickets
verkauft und er hat dann einfach
noch mal ich weiß gar nicht wie viel das
war zum Börsengang ich glaube 200 oder
zwei möchten wir eher 2000 Optionen
verkauft
zu der Zeit aber schon auch bei Herrn
ist
also das liegt da auch auf einer Bank
wird auch verzinst von ihm und so also
ist alles und ich kann es jederzeit
zurückholen wenn ich es brauche oder ich
kann es dann irgendwann als Anzahlung
für ein Ticket nutzen ja so und jetzt
sind wir also den landungsvorgang der
demnächst beginnt oder bzw schon
begonnen hat vielleicht da auch noch mal
die Frage an unser Fachpersonal was ist
da jetzt noch irgendwie zu beachten ist
das etwas was auch noch mal eine
kritische Phase ist man sagt ja so in
der
passagierfliegerei das Start- und
Landung immer ein bisschen heikel sind
wie muss man da jetzt als Pilot vorgehen
naja natürlich
fragen nehme ich an dass dieser
Flugkörper genauso wie das Space Shuttle
keinen Treibstoff mehr hat und keinen
Antrieb das heißt der Pilot muss hier
die Landebahn beim ersten Mal treffen da
gibt es keinen zweiten Versuch da kann
man immer mehr durchstarten bin aber
überzeugt dass sind sehr gut trainierte
Piloten und die die schaffen das vor
allem die wetterverhältnisses sind sehr
gut also das sollte absolut nichts
schief gehen aber auch ein interessanter
Punkt ne stimmt ja kein Treibstoff kein
durchstarten möglich also man hat im
Prinzip nur einen Versuch da ist dann
schon höchste Konzentration erforderlich
jetzt sehen wir da ist auch noch ein
anderes Flugzeug mit dabei vielleicht
auch um die Aufnahmen zu machen
kleineres Flugzeug offensichtlich
so aber das scheint mir hier so eine Art
Segelflug zu sein happy birgs so ähnlich
hatten sie es auch beschrieben vorhin ja
genau so ist es das ist ein Segelflug
und ich glaube es hat euch dann den
Touchdown also viel fehlt immer mehr das
Richter dass ich aus und teilt die
Landebahn an
genau
sehr vergleichbar mit der Beschattung
Frau Kessler fällt ihnen noch was auf
wenn sie das Flugzeug so heran schweben
sehen
ja es ist natürlich immer noch super
elegant also ganz klar so und jetzt
jetzt sehen wir gleich den Touchdown
denke ich so das sieht relativ
weich und gut kontrolliert aus
da sollte doch eigentlich jetzt nichts
schief gehen das wird schon applaudiert
an Bord der Kabine also da unterscheiden
sie sich auch nicht vom Flug nach
Mallorca da wird auch immer geklatscht
wenn er dann gut gelandet ist habe ich
mir sagen lassen ja gut der Trip ging
jetzt ein bisschen weiter ins alte
zumindest hinaus als der normale
Passagierflug aber da ist immer noch mal
die Maschine von hinten bei der Landung
das schaut gut aus ja also Herr Benson
kann sich jetzt auch ans rewheften dass
er der erste ist der mit seinem eigenen
privaten Unternehmen ins Weltall
geflogen ist wenn es auch nur für eine
gute Stunde war bzw dann die Zeit oben
natürlich noch wesentlich kürzer war
aber das ist mit Sicherheit etwas das
hat er ja auch gerade schon in seinem
ersten Statement gesagt was ihn sein
Leben lang begleiten wird und worauf er
sehr stolz sein dürfte dass ihm das eben
gelungen ist als Unternehmer und auch
als Abenteurer der ja nun mal auch ist
da steht der Vogel also wieder in der
Wüste von New Mexico es wird geklatscht
höre ich auch noch mal über die
Mikrofone unten auch im Weltraumbahnhof
dürfte die Stimmung entsprechend sein
so
ich höre gerade dass unsere Kollegin
gerade nicht für uns erreichbar ist vor
Ort
ah okay doch
das Bild ist nicht da aber wir hören Sie
Nina Niva geil du hörst uns wie ist die
Stimmung vor Ort alle euphorisch
komisch also es wurde mehrmals
applaudiert bei den diversen wichtigen
Momenten die ihr gerade in aller
Ausführlichkeit auch besprochen habt und
vor allem jetzt auch als alle noch mal
sicher hier am Boden angekommen sind ist
natürlich Jubel ausgebrochen und was
total beeindruckend war muss ich sagen
was die Leute hier auch sehr beeindruckt
hat dass man natürlich sowohl den
Flieger am Anfang aber dann vor allem
auch das Raumschiff am Himmel gesehen
hat als es auf einer gewissen Höhe war
hat man das natürlich nicht mehr gesehen
aber bis dahin konnte man es hier
durchstarten sehen und man konnte es
auch wieder landen sehen das war
sicherlich für alle Beteiligten ein sehr
wunderbar Nina Dankeschön wir haben dich
gut verstanden das Bild ist leider ein
bisschen eingefroren aber danke noch mal
für deine Eindrücke von vor Ort in der
lieber geil war das aus der Wüste von
New Mexico für uns und dann kommen wir
noch mal zurück zu unseren beiden
Experten vielleicht für ein letztes
Fazit Frau Kessler und Herr Fieberg wie
sehen insgesamt diese Tour gefallen
glauben Sie das ist sozusagen etwas was
jetzt Schule machen wird wird es von
diesen Aktionen mehr geben in Zukunft
ladies
ganz bestimmt wird es jetzt mehr davon
geben ich glaube nächstes Jahr soll es
dann auch wirklich losgehen die werden
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen testen und
dann wirklich die kommerziellen Flüge
die Touristen werden ab nächstes Jahr
dann fliegen die ja alle schon langen
Ticket haben und lang auf ihren Flug
warten und das ist vielleicht zum
Schluss noch mal sagen möchte was
Richard Branson ja auch betont hat ist
dass ihr hofft dass viele Kinder sich
auch und ich hoffe natürlich Mädchen und
Jungs dafür inspirieren lassen das zu
sehen und auch selbst dann in die
Technik zu gehen in der Technik zu
arbeiten man muss ja nicht unbedingt
Astronaut werden aber einfach sich mehr
für den Weltraum für die Technik
begeistern engagieren und da auch
technologisch dann natürlich noch mal
eine sehr neugierige und innovative
Generation heranwachsen wird
ja das ist ein gutes Fazit Herr fiebert
was denken sie
ja ich bin einmal froh dass das gut
gegangen ist heute das ist einmal tolle
Leistung die das ganze Ding da gezeigt
hat der Richard Branson ist zu bewundert
in seinem Alter so etwas zu machen ist
auch beispielhaft da zeigt dass man
durchaus im hohen Alter auch noch viel
machen kann und das ganze wird Schule
machen also die haben sicherlich viel
gelernt heute wieder bei dem Flug bei
jedem weiteren Flug lernen die dazu es
wird sicherer und so gesehen werden
solche Flüge bald von einer viel
größeren Anzahl von Menschen benützt
werden ja und dann hoffentlich eben auch
zu Preisen die dann eben auch
erschwinglich sind aber das wird noch
eine Weile dauern Richard Branson sagt
dir immer als die Luftfahrt überhaupt
begonnen hat also auch die Fliegerei war
das am Anfang auch alles sehr teuer und
wurde dann mit der Zeit günstiger könnte
also durchaus sein dass das dann auch
fast das Weltraum erfahren bzw fliegen
dorthin dann angeht genauso sein wird
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für die
Expertise von Ihnen beiden und dass sie
uns heute zur Verfügung gestanden haben
um diesen Flug zu kommentieren von
Richard Branson ins Weltall danke schön
auch an euch noch mal für eure Fragen
und Kommentare ja wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen wir haben ja dann doch einige
doch finde ich sehr spannende und
interessante Bilder noch zeigen können
also Dankeschön an alle Beteiligten und
euch einen schönen restlichen Sonntag
bis demnächst ciao ciao